Hey youtubers is Charlie! And if you didn't see the awesome news, John Wesley
Shipp, the original Flash just got cast
on the new show
and Stephen Amell just said the whole
bunch of those characters are
coming on Arrow.
Someone is also getting a shiny new
superhero suit before the Arrow finale
this year too.
Everybody high five each other! All right
so let's do a quick breakdown of all that news
starting with the Arrow stuff.
So Stephen Amell said that Central City
characters are coming the Arrow
this season.
That's characters plural, meaning Grant
Gustin and at least one other person will
be coming.
He also said that the characters would
bounce back and forth next season at
least in cameos.
They'll probably do a special episode like the
midseason finale when Grant Gustin
debuted as Barry Allen.
You know, like mini-team ups. Mini Justice
League episodes
if you will. No idea who that other Flash
character will be.
You know, the one is coming to Arrow before
the end of the season. But its most
likely going to be one of the other people
they cast recently.
My bet is on Iris West, just because we
had a really nice Triangle 'Ship between
Felicity, Barry and Iris.
I can already see the Tumblr gifs in my
mind. This is going to be ridiculous :)
In related Arrow news there will also be
one more costume hero on the show before
the end of the season.
All signs are pointing to Roy
getting his "Real Deal" red outfit.
I would bet on it looking like a version
of Oliver's suit.
Previously I predicted he'd get the suit after
they defeated Slade, but Stephen Amell
based on what he said, is making it sound like that will happen sooner.
So onto Flash news! John Wesley Shipp has
been cast in a
secret role, so let's try and
guess who that is. Right now my money is
either on
him being Grant Gustin's father, Barry Allen's father or *fingers crossed*
Jay Garrick. It sounds like it's going to be
a really substantial role whatever it is,
so I'm thinking he's going to be like
a Moira Queen type person
on the show.
Like a supporting character who's just
really important. The main cast will
still be Grant Gustin and
Iris West, her father Detective West and
Edward THawne.
If he is playing Barry Allen's father,
That means he is going to spend most
of Season 1 in prison.
And I think that his role is going to
be one that allows him to be on screen.
So I don't think that is as likely.
The real question is, Why would they
keep his character a secret if it wasn't
something huge?
That's really where my Jay Garrick
speculation comes from. Speaking of
Meta-Moments,
Shipp also starred as Professor Zoom on
Brave and the Bold.
So he has played other versions of the
Flash since that 1990s series.
No matter who he turns out to be though,
I'm getting super pumped. Geoff Johns
was not kidding when he said they're going all out for the series.
The important thing to remember about
all this is that they have not started
filming the pilot yet.
And it has to be given a series order
before actually turns into a TV Show.
Worst-case scenario everything falls
through, you can still breathe easy.
Because Grant Gustin
and all these other characters they cast
will still be a part of Arrow.
So we will get the Flash no matter what. They
will keep those characters inside the CW
Universe.
So we will see them again no matter what.
My 2 big questions for you guys
are #1 - Who do you think John Wesley Shipp is playing? You know is it Jay Garrick,
or is it some other character? And #2 - Do you think that Roy will get that costume
before the end of the season?
Since the pilot starts filming in March,
they're going to continue to make casting
announcements and hopefully we'll find
out stuff from the set, so be sure to
SUBSCRIBE to get all my videos.
I'll be doing a lot more regular bonus
Flash videos as we move forward.
Next week will be more bonus videos, but
I'll try to do another Flash Bonus
video too.
Maybe like my Top 5 Stories they
should adapt for Season 1.
Because there's a whole bunch of stuff they
could be doing. Right now click here to
get my
Top 5 reasons why Loki is going to be
on Agents Of SHIELD this season.
And click here to get my first preview
for the Flash TV Show.
Thank You so much for watching, see you
guys Tonight. HIGH FIVES!